jetzt geht's um die fünf prozent hürde
bei den bundestagswahlen was steckt
genau dahinter es gibt etliche parteien
die es nicht in den bundestag schaffen
obwohl sie von wirklich vielen leuten
gewählt werden und grund dafür ist die
fünf prozent hürde grundsätzlich ist es
so jede partei die mindestens fünf
prozent aller zweitstimmen erhält
schafft ins parlament und ziel dieser
regelung ist es eine zu starke
zersplitterung des parlamentes zu
verhindern es gibt allerdings auch ein
weg wie es parteien mit weniger als 5
prozent in den bundestag schaffen und
das geht mit sogenannten direktmandaten
gewinnt der kandidat oder die kandidatin
einer partei einen wahlkreis direkt
zieht sie oder er auf jeden fall ein und
schafft es eine partei drei
direktmandate zu gewinnen dann wird auch
ihr zweitstimmenanteil bei der
sitzverteilung berücksichtigt und eben
auch dann wenn die partei unter fünf
prozent kommt